oh my goodness look at these investors
from that ad from that add all these
investors now am i frigging mailing
lists wanting to buy houses right now
during this period of time like that is
we freaking ridiculous
so yesterday put the video out and I
said that during this isolation lockdown
while I'm in quarantine I was going to
try and do some property deals make some
property money and I was going to
document it and I want everyone to do
this together so what are the solid it
is rather than me do it and then put
some little edit together and put some
twenty minute video out and we were
today I'm not going to do that I don't
even know if there's going to be today I
don't know if it's gonna work I'm just
gonna vlog it and document it exactly
raw as it is as I go and you can do the
same if you want or you can share ideas
with me and and help me in this but I
think I know what I'm gonna do I've been
thinking long and hard about the
strategies and here's what I'm thinking
okay so right now is it you might think
it's a terrible time right now to invest
in property because the market is
crashing but the fit but here's the
thing okay
how am I going to make some money right
now okay two ways I'm not gonna I'm not
going to save money up and just buy
buy-to-let property right now I'm not
saying that's a bad thing to do people
are doing that not so nice bad property
usually will win long-term but I want to
get some fast cash in and I also I also
want to have my cake and eat it people
say you should never have any you know
you can't have your cake and eat it in
property you can have your cake and eat
it so there's the strategies that I'm
thinking they're gonna work right now
and I've shared this I think people have
been instagramming me dealing me and
saying what's your strategy and I've
been saying here's my strategy I just
have a laptop I'm just at home in
lockdown I can't do viewings the stages
can't go out and do things for me it's
tough
my strategy is going to be deal sourcing
deal packaging and it's gonna be lease
option agreements because the the crazy
good thing I'm thinking about lease
option agreements right now is when I've
got my lease option agreement back in
the day when I first started doing it it
was it was it was just just after the
crash it was when people scared as ever
it was like 2009 when property prices
rocketed
people wanted out that was when I was
getting in on a lease option agreement
where you're having cake and eat it
because what I mean by that I'll give
you an example and I'm gonna be jumping
on the computer in a moment but imagine
that you're selling something like you
imagine if I'm selling this computer but
this computer is filthy and it's covered
in dirt and stuff like like I'm gonna
shut that door I can hear I can hear too
much noise I'm just thinking if it's
covered in dirt I'm not gonna be able to
sell it for very much money because it's
covered in dirt okay so I'll just be
able to sell it for a cheap price
because no one wants it when it's
covered in dirt so it goes really cheap
then you clean it up and then it's worth
more expensive in the same way in the
property market right now the dirt is
the is the scarcity is the fear is
everything that's going on so if you buy
a property now while everyone is scared
you can get proper cheap deals so my
thinking is I want to get proper cheap
deals but I don't want to put any money
down I want to have an option to buy it
while we're in bad times but then have
the option to buy it in five or seven
years time and then if it goes up in
value
boom I'm mad I've got instant cash flow
from it so that's what I'm wanting to do
but I'm also wanting to package your
sell deals I know right now people are
are buying I know right now people are
selling I mean on Instagram people are
literally I I said yesterday into the
financial freedom challenge I was gonna
start doing deals I told people I want
you to do it as well hashtag a lockdown
property challenge people are DMing me
and i'm DMing them back so this guy
messaged me and says I'm up for the
challenge could I do in Holland but the
same story is everywhere right now like
in Holland it's the same as the UK is
the same all over the world I just told
him my strategy should do it and tell
what you do he's now I'm told I told him
I'm gonna do lease option agreement deal
sauce and that's what I'm thinking
I'm messaging him if we fail who cares
if we fail who cares hey buddy
so so so he messaged me just now
literally half an hour ago stone just
got in contact with a lamb
Lord who has a pretty big property
portfolio probably gonna have some rent
to rent deals I will help him polish
tenants which he always he has blah blah
blah blah
in return giving me a very good price on
some of his properties like he's now
talking to animals but I'm motivated so
right now motivated landlords are
existing more than ever so here's the
crazy thing here's what I'm thinking are
you gonna are you gonna join me or are
you gonna go and play I'm gonna take him
away I'm gonna be straight back okay
come on Nate come on mate hey here's
your stuff daddy's making money man
daddy's making money right now
so so what I'm thinking is this if I
found a list of properties that will
motivate you to sell but how do you find
them right now I can't go on networking
I can't know a few properties what I'm
thinking is this online crazy think
about the computer who's it knows
everything about you this computer knows
so much about me my lights my interests
which is scary but as a marketer it's
not scary it's exciting because I'm
gonna set up right now and I'm gonna
just I'm gonna do some of a-kor my
screen I'll show you I'm going to set up
a Facebook ad I'm gonna set up to
Facebook Ads I'm gonna set up a Facebook
ad targeted motivated sellers and
landlords and I'm gonna say hey you know
are you wanting to sell your property
right now in these scary times have you
got a property myself if you want to
sell I will give you an instant
valuation on your property boom in
exchange for the address if you're
motivated to sell put your details in
here and I'm gonna start marketing with
nominal money and I'll show you exactly
how much I'm spending and how many
people are giving me their details I'm
gonna start building a motivated seven's
list right now in it today in these
times and then I'm gonna set up another
list another advert which is going to be
a Facebook advert which is targeted for
bias because right now I know there's
people said buying houses right now
because I'm selling some of my houses
and people people I've got the auction
date coming up but people are coming in
with cash wanting to dump their money
they're coming from China they're coming
from Australia they're coming from
different parts of the UK wanting to buy
cash properties and they're wanting to
buy my problems that I'm selling I'm
thinking people are buy people are
buying so I want to set up a another
Facebook ad and I'm going to show you
everything I'm going to do it and
Facebook out is gonna be for buyers so
hey are you looking to put your cash
into UK proper to market right now wild
properties are going cheap give us your
details so I'll start I'm gonna start
building from scratch from my computer
and I'm gonna record my screen me
building an investor list me building a
motivated sellers list and then I'm just
gonna start bringing them together and
charging them a fee charging the
investor fee and I'm just gonna have to
figure out how I can't obviously view
the property but I can get some maybe
surveys I can get surveys on the
property I'm gonna just try have a bash
to see what happens and then the really
the motivate sellers that I like I can't
go that low then I'll say how about I'll
offer you a lease option agreement and
the creme of the creme deals I'm gonna
keep for myself so I'm gonna get some
cash flow from deal source in I'm gonna
get my cake and eat it by getting some
lease option agreements and this is a
scratch as scratch as scratch can be
because I've nothing I can't leave the
house I'm on my computer so I'll record
the screen and I'm gonna start building
those lists and start setting up those
adverts but man honestly people are
messaging me like crazy of you you need
to be doing this as well and share your
ideas with me because people are people
are making I think it's too much of a
good sell as a deal so we're looking to
take on us house don't have any capital
at the moment and what would you advise
the best sort of things to move forward
with there okay cool so she see this is
what I'm talking about like I'm gonna
I'm gonna I want to throw her back in a
bit and I'm not even record the
conversation put it in here so right now
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna build
a buyer's list of motivated investors
they don't want to build a sellers list
motivated sellers from scratch on
Facebook me to show you every step of
the way and then the the sellers that
have got the properties if they're good
I'll pass them on if they're really good
I'll keep them somehow I'll keep them
somehow but I'm not gonna put any money
into this I'm gonna do from a lock that
into my house any money that do putting
is gonna be like minimal like Facebook
Ads a little bit I'm asked to pay a
severe potentially but I'm gonna do this
on it on a budget like a legit budget
and I'll show you every pound I spend
and we'll see what we can get okay
Facebook Ads see normally my team do all
my marketing and stuff but back in the
day when I started I've done a bit of
Facebook Ads thank God so let's do this
okay so I'm um this is my facebook now
in order to do Facebook Ads
you do need a Facebook account and you
do need a Facebook page so when you
click on here you probably don't really
see all this nonsense but there's
actually a little manage ads but boom
shocka
second business Samuel Leeds now believe
it or not because of coronavirus even
Facebook ad of taking a hit because the
Facebook have said that they take longer
to approve is not as usual because
they've not got so many staff so
honestly everything is just crazy your
personal ad account create okay so
traffic engagement which one we want I'm
gonna go for the lead generation now it
doesn't matter too much which one you
click it's just a case of Facebook
charge you in different ways depending
on what you want to get and all I want
to go for lead gems which means actually
people filling out form okay you
campaign name this is gonna be for
motivated sellers now daily budget I
don't want to spend a lot of money on
this I'm gonna put maybe fifteen pounds
a day to start with and see how we got
on with there but if I if I'm only
getting a couple a day tripping through
I might need to put that up a little bit
but I think fifteen pounds a day should
be enough to give me to give me some
decent leads if I come at the ad right
okay so this is now where I'm gonna
begin to stop putting together that Who
am I going to be buying from so I'm
thinking UK where do I want these
property deals well if I'm looking for
the lease option agreement I could be
going to negative equity areas but with
the crisis that's going on I don't even
think it needs to be just negative
equity areas I don't want to be spending
a fortune on buying a house even though
I'm not buying it one day I probably
will buy it if it's a lease option
agreement Birmingham gone well you've
been 25 miles of Birmingham and I'm also
gonna do oh where should we go should we
go I want someone with negative equity
but not really far north because if I
ever do have to drive there not that
I'll be able to endure isolation
I think Doncaster could be good within
25 miles I'm going to
south wales as brilliant as australia is
no I tell you what I'll put in caught it
okay that will probably do for now those
are my areas sorry you can hear my
computer overheating a little bit a heed
range
I don't want 18 to 65 because I'm not
being funny but if I'm looking for
distressed sellers they're probably
gonna be old older than 18 I'm gonna be
looking for that's a 40 now what I'm
doing is I'm just choosing exactly who I
want to target my odds to 40 to 59
that's a good age because that's kind of
like going up to retirement age if you
were 40 to 59 right now you could be
going through a little bit of a midlife
crisis
you could be thinking that arm man I
just want to tight you know so I don't
want to get people of necessarily like
in the 60s and 70s that are retiring but
I think that is a good age and a lot of
my properties that I've I tend to be
that sort of ages genders I'm not being
sexist at all here but I'm gonna go for
men just because I think that man
probably tend to be more likely to be
investors that sounds awful but yeah do
you know what it's not even awful it's
just a case of I'm targeting people that
I like for like so people that I've
bought properties from in the past
motivated sellers have been men mostly
mostly in this age so I'm just I'm just
going off with my experience of what I
know works detailed targeting yes please
so include people who match okay let's
have a look so behaviors
let's see what we can find finance wise
so financial I see there's so much stuff
here where you how you can target people
behaviors so let us see what kind of
people were looking for so we're looking
for expat so we're looking for I mean
right now I'm thinking purchase behavior
big good one and we can maybe find
people who are did I engaged shoppers so
people are engaged to shoppers might be
people that could potentially have
spending habits there could be a
financial difficulty a little bit not
trying to prey on people in financial
difficulty but just trying to find
people that I vomit is difficulty that
we might be able to help and it could
also be let's see what else we got
okay interests family and relationships
so I'm thinking we want to get people
that are married fatherhood yeah and
Facebook just not always stuff about you
I'm thinking DIY people are good because
as crazy as this sounds if you're like a
DIY person you don't you literally do
everything yourself and if you've got a
couple of properties where you're
allowing look to them you so hands-on
and in this time about you've been
obviously the house property of tenants
it's just like it's often the DIY type
people thus become tired landlords
interests what are these people
interested in family relationships I
think these people are going to be
people they're homeowners homeowner
they're going to be people we're looking
for father's people are married looking
people that engage shoppers people that
might have and then particularly
electric vehicle now what you'll see is
we become more and more specific is you
you cannot this is getting a bit more a
little bit less broad now now you can
say they've got to have all these things
and you can really narrow it
they need all of them at the moment it's
just all so that's why we're doing this
all this all this but I personally think
we should narrow the audience down a
little bit more and say that they are
okay what would they be interested in
what would these people read where would
they go
they are tired landlords job Tata
landlord yeah absolutely so now if their
landlords that are also any of these
things and engage shopper father DIY
time kind of person then these could be
really really interesting people and
speak to you I now anything else let's
see whales suggestions maybe they've got
a holiday coming up or a new house did
you see that one and we can play with
this if the ad doesn't work very well we
can always come back and change it and
play this is not something where you
just do a perfect ad so now this is a
bit too few now saying that fewer than a
thousand people are actually going to be
able to be reached which is too specific
so you don't want it to be too broad
John to be too specific you definitely
it's somewhere in the green so maybe we
need to just remove some of these things
a little bit because very - you've got
to have it one of these and also be a
landlord so let's tell let's get rid of
the let's get rid of this and see what
happens
see if it brings it back into the green
financial freedom challenge in an
overheated computer with slow Wi-Fi from
home ok so now I need to decide what
they're going to see when they see the
ad are they going to see a carousel
which is two or more scrollable images
or a single image or video I'm going to
go with a single image or video and I'm
thinking I'm probably gonna do a video
because I am pretty compelling on video
but you could just do an image which
says you know something like sell your
house quick I want to buy your house or
take complete control no I just want to
buy it
because the thing is oh I'm thinking
lease option agreement but first I'm
gonna go in to buy below market value
and then if they don't want to do that
then fine I want to buy your house I am
looking for existing landlords that the
only people that are going to see this
advert advert our existing landlords so
if I say I want to buy your house I'm
looking for existing landlords that's
like interesting to them I want to buy
your house I'm looking for existing
landlords who are open who are wanting a
quick cash offer during
ovid 19 crisis if you have houses in
South Wales Doncaster or Birmingham if
you have houses within 25 miles of sick
I know these people are landlords with
properties within 25 miles of those
places or Birmingham please what's gonna
be the call to action please now I could
give them a link to something I could
give them a link to something but I'm
not going to on the side please message
me on Facebook looking for landlords
selling guard display the link so I
really could do be putting a link to a
web site of some kind now I do have a
website I have is my little plug now if
you're a landlord that's motivated
interesting properties like how do you
go and but this website I promise you is
so simple to set up like this takes like
this takes it just takes so little time
so now about this so but so I'm gonna
put this and maybe I should do another
video and show you how to set up a
website like that in literally 10
minutes if you want to see that then
just prom
so I went to have website and it will
cost you nearly nothing to set up a
website like that get offered that's
what they've won they want an offer or
they want a quote I'm gonna change this
drop me a message Dean because I just
don't think I don't know if it will work
I've never tried that before I was kind
of thinking of you guys that might not
have a website but I think I just need I
think you just need to get a website so
please fill in your property details for
a quick offer I'll change this about
that separately instead of message me on
Facebook now it's going to be please
fill out your property details now let's
have a chat nice now I don't want this
desk thing because that's just not
really gonna be compelling I want a
video because that currently have a
video but I'm gonna do a video right now
and again sometimes like you can
overthink doing a video but I'm gonna
keep this really simple okay this is the
actual video that's gonna go out there
so - any leads
I'm actively looking for landlords to
buy properties right now during this
Cove in nineteen crisis if you're a
landlord and you're looking to shift off
some of your properties I really would
love to have a conversation with you
listen on a businessperson so of course
I'm looking to get a good price but I
can move fast I've got the cash
available and I don't necessarily need
to rely on lenders so regardless of
whether what the situation is with the
economy right now I'm wanting to move I
want to have a chat with you if you've
got properties fill your details and
below on the link instant - property
stock where do you care it's my website
I'll be able to give you an instant
valuation offer usually I say
interesting news move it about an hour
or so so fille details in let's have a
chat and hopefully we can do business
together and I can shift some of the
property headaches from your hands right
now in 2020 okay so it's to the point it
was direct I put the date on it I
mentioned that the the the virus so that
is the video which I want to put up if
it flops and if it doesn't work then
I'll redo
all right let's let's upload this I'm
just gonna a drop this right onto my
computer save to downloads there it is
video uploading it says recommended
length is 15 seconds or less but to be
honest I think I'm kind of reasonably
engaging so even though it is more
mine's about 45 seconds I think I'm
gonna give it a bash and and see and see
what happens I want to buy your house
there we go cuz I'll just grab their
eyes a bit more i grabbing there we go
with the video which is loading we
should be ready in a second with that
video with that text to the right people
I mean with the website which is nice
website which is very simple simple is
king keep it simple stupid
the reason I was able to become
financially free when I started are 17
by by age 21 was because I was stupid I
was naive keep it simple stupid people
overcomplicate this business and
constantly overthink it but don't
actually just press the button and press
submit of those who usually get nowhere
and end up as five landlords when
they're in their 40s and 50s instead of
financially free people in their 20s
looking for landlords setting up mmm no
I'm gonna change that as well too oh you
need not consider needing to sell your
properties quickly there we go there we
go I'm feeling this advert man I'm
feeling this advert this is the con
stuff I never normally put on YouTube
okay almost done almost done
I'm excited it's happening baby
oh there it is there's the art landlord
spell right but that just looks weird
landlord I want to buy your house I'm
looking for existing landlords who are
wanting quick cash offer due to coconut
they're just gonna click see what
they're gonna watch that video they're
gonna they're gonna click suck why does
it say sana
that is to say get offer all you need to
sell your properties quickly get offer
right
nice nice nice original recommended
let's just go would they recommend it oh
oh I look a little bit closed up but
let's see how that looks
it could even be more powerful fair
enough
right crop video processing this is
getting close now so wait this is see
how quick this is from scratch just my
bank Facebook guard and I'm only gonna
be point 15 pound a day
some people are paying 15 pounds to get
people to stand in queues for them
outside Tesco's right now oh this looks
nice interested for oh so facebook let
you create an interest form now see I've
not seen this before I've not seen this
before
email for name so you can add get them
to ask you questions how awesome is this
so this guy's is is so phenomenal
because it means you don't even need a
website but you can just literally say
to them hey give me give us your details
like rather than over the website just
on the ad which is brilliant so let me
do this as well question we do need that
email we do want their name so I'm gonna
ask a new question I don't care about
what their date of birth and stuff is I
want to know how what would there enjoy
what the address of their property is so
I'm gonna say street address
and add a new question can I can I make
up my own question here
multiple choice conditional add a new
question short answer there we go
short answer what is the lowest you
could accept if bought cash today
today's probably a little extreme
tomorrow and then they can write that
little short answer so now we've got the
email their name the address of the
property and what the lowest they could
accepted my boy cash tomorrow is so I
think that will probably do so there's
next this see that's what it's going to
look like which is fantastic and then
that's the thank you screen and then
then they can view the website I'm
liking this Franklin okay so that is now
in draft so that doesn't sound right
ah it's active that was exciting in
review you've successfully submitted
your ad when someone submits response
your form they become a lead for your
business here is how you can access your
leaves you can either just download a
CBC file which is basically like a
spreadsheet or you can set up a CRM
system
now I've already set up a CRM system I'm
interested to see though what Facebook
recommend I have a serious one called
all clients which again you can set up
to free and then it's like 20 pound a
month after 14 days or something like
that but Facebook recommend one so that
is the a burden for the landlords for
the motivated sellers it's waiting to be
improved my facebook now I'm gonna do
one way for her to be approved so have a
quick check on my wife and check she's
okay and then I'm gonna do this exact
same thing again but this time for
investors to build my investor list I
just know what she is forget it I do
now I'm gonna set this looking for
investors between 25 and 45 all genders
because there's a lot of women at the
moment looking to buy properties
property investment Rich Dad Poor Dad
Warren Buffett if he's not putting these
people's because if they're interested
in people like Warren Buffett when
Warren Buffett says very famously when
people are scared that's when you should
be greedy if they're interested in
property interests I think Warren
Buffett there's a chance that they might
be interested in buying property right
now assuming I can find the right kind
of properties it's in the green that's
good if you're looking to invest in the
UK right now or people are scared and
they're freaking out and they're selling
that house is really cheap they're
you're in the right place my name is
Samuel Leeds I'm a property deal
sorcerer I would suggest you join my
mailing list for free and I'll send you
the juiciest most below-market by you
deal that I'm fighting right now join
the list or soon to the deals now I
actually have any deals right now but
I'm still advertising the fact that as
if I have got deals but I'm doing that
I'm in faith that I'm gonna get some
deals from the other advert which hasn't
even been approved yet but okay
subscribe and I'm gonna use this form
and I'm just gonna get them on an Excel
spreadsheet so you could literally do
this from scratch this is just
absolutely P simple that's all we need
email and full-name we don't need much
more from at this point because if
you've got that email and full name and
we've got deals then we can just start
sending their deals out to their email
which is great okay I'm gonna have to
put a link in here up here so I'm just
gonna put a link to the instant
properties page so at least they can see
a little who I am and see a little bit
about mine
but you could literally put any link
here you could put a link to your
probably even a link to your Facebook
page in fact I'm going to do that
because everybody has a Facebook page we
have it second is now it's closed
hanging draft have
yeah it's changed too in review 15 pound
a day in review so now yeah that will
work the CVC so now now there might be
some glitches I don't know the odds
might not be accepted I don't know so
we've got the lead generation out for
the motivated sellers in with you we've
got the motivated sellers in with you so
now it's just the waiting game so the
time is not 10 20 pieces 31st of March
so that means tomorrow's April tomorrow
is April Fool's Day so I'll probably
have edited this and I'll probably post
it on the 1st of April April Fools don't
know ten twenty thirty first of March my
ad has still not been approved on
Facebook so I'm gonna go to bed and I'm
gonna hope that it's approved tomorrow
and hopefully tomorrow I'm gonna start
getting some motivated sellers some
buyers listen to do Lease Option
agreements even in lockdown all you need
is you need a really motivated seller
and you need a good solicitor and you
need a good negotiator I have those
three things to be able to package and
sell bills even in lockdown
you don't need a car mr. Cheryl oh it's
gonna be a bit tricky but I'm thinking
this I need a really motivated seller I
need an investor and I need a good
salesperson a good negotiator in the
middle to bring the two together we have
the recipe here for success I believe
that on believe in and I'm gonna be
updating every day maybe like every day
maybe every couple days but I'm gonna be
updating my progress showing you exactly
what I'm doing
as I'm doing it live time and now I hope
you enjoy the video look forward to
seeing you guys do the same again if you
want to see more detail let me know if
this video was too long let me know I
also want to see what you're doing so
maybe post a video yourself feel free to
drop me a DM on Instagram I try and
respond to as many as I can also use the
hashtag lock down property challenge
we're all locked down it's a challenge
but we're going to continue being
successful in property I'll see you guys
real soon
day 2 of the lock down challenge and I'm
gonna check see if my dad has been
accepted it's the first of April I'm
hoping that it's because it's the first
of April I'm hoping that we're gonna
find out that this whole Korona thing is
just one big joke and the government
times today that if you only
but I doubt that's going to happen okay
let's say it's loading I hope it's been
accepted so bad about time to just mess
around
oh okay so the lead generation one it's
been accepted that's annoying though
because the oh my gosh and I've had 29
results that is insane and it's cost me
16 pence per result and a result was a
lead gen that I can't believe it
the other thing is worrying is the fact
that the motivated sellers ad is still
not live so now I'm not all these
investors saying I wanna buy no alibi
and I'm not gonna have any deals okay
let me see who these these people are
that's been finicky and then they filled
out the form in-house on Facebook so
I've got investors now coming so I've
got 29 investors 16 peer made and it's
cost me four pounds 73 in total less
than a fiver and I've got 29 investors
interested that is ridiculous that is a
win I'm just bummed out but I haven't
got the leads from motivated sellers
maybe I'll need to go on to maybe I need
to go on gumtree which really deals
because these investors are gonna want
something oh my goodness look at these
investors from that ad from that add all
these investors now my frigging mailing
list wanting to buy houses right now
during this period of time like that is
re freakin ridiculous I've got their
emails I can now email these people with
my deals I just don't have any deals so
I need to Facebook to hurry their asses
up and get this deal because honestly
once I've got once I've got the same but
with motivated sellers you what I'll be
on the phone I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
I'm gonna be against
sails in like this is happening
you